[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureuse de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du
c'est une culture le premier de l'année
2019 et tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mardi 8 janvier
c'est un rendez-vous dorénavant installé
dans les yvelines le festival électro
chic revient pour sa troisième édition
et cette année encore de jeunes artistes
peuvent se lancer grâce au tremplin
elle dialogue en noir et blanc patricia
- et nathalie ou de binh s'inspirent de
leur environnement leurs oeuvres se
répondent dans une exposition commune à
aiguillon et cette deuxième partie de
saison propose encore de très beaux
rendez vous nous ferons le point sur
quelques uns d'entre eux qui rythmeront
l'actualité nous recevrons aussi sur ce
plateau hervé farges le président de la
bm s cube pour parler des concerts
classiques de ces prochains mois nous
parlerons aussi théâtre avec
l'association mauricienne site m
mais on débute avec de la musique
électronique depuis trois ans le
festival électro chic fait vibrer
versailles grand parc de grands noms
vous seront délégués durant trois jours
pour cette troisième édition aussi le
talent le tremplin revient cyril le
boulaire bonjour je vous êtes le
secrétaire général de l'onda
vélizy-villacoublay l'une des salles qui
reçoit le festival cette année encore
vous recherchez des pépites qui seront
se produire le 15 mars
oui complètement alors le principe de ce
tremplin c'est de donner la possibilité
à tous les passionnés de musique
électronique de se produire dans les
conditions réelles professionnelle d'un
vrai concert électro
voilà donc le tremplin le festival aura
lieu du 14 au 16 mars et le 15 mars
il y à ce tremplin des jeunes talents
électro enfin jeunes et moins jeunes
d'ailleurs puisque je ne pense plutôt à
ceux qui démarrent qui sont amateurs
dans la création exactement puisque pour
participer à ce tremplin il faut avoir
au moins 16 ans il n'a pas de limite
d'âge
les candidatures ont été ouvertes depuis
mois de décembre donc vous pouvez encore
candidate et jusqu'au 1er février 17
heures dernier délai voilà il faudra
nous envoyer une maquette avec
une ou deux compositions de 10 minutes
maximum électro bien sûr et une reprise
du groupe daft punk de 5 minutes maximum
dans 15 minutes maximum d' écoute à la
suite de quoi on va décider de cinq
candidats qui se produiront le 15 mars
et bien sûr il y aura un vainqueur un
gagnant voilà qui sera désigné à la fois
par le public et par un jury d'experts
de quatre personnes et ceux gagnant aura
la possibilité de se produire à titre
professionnel en tant qu'artiste invité
l'année prochaine en 2020 ont dît il
faut faire des musiques électro bien sûr
mais c'est très très large
est ce que vous recherchez des styles en
particulier au contraire peut-être un
peu de nouveauté
oui c'est le principe des musiques
électroniques 1 c'est un type de musique
qui brasse énormément de styles
différents
évidemment rien ce n'est absolument pas
fermée c'est ouvert
donc il n'y a pas de style pré-requis
dans les musiques électroniques sont
vraiment très très large une fois que
ces cinq sont choisis peut-être certains
n'ont pas l'habitude de la scène est ce
qu'ils seront déjà des avant goûts il ya
des répétitions de l'aide de techniciens
comment ça va se passer pour ces cinq là
oui avec des dés le matin donc dans la
journée du 15
ils seront accueillis à londres
évidemment ils seront accompagnés
techniquement pour se produire dans les
meilleures conditions le soir du
spectacle
alors vous l'avez dit janin qui sera
choisi par le public notamment celle
idée aussi d'avnet faire partager les
goûts de chacun
pourtant votre comment ça se passait à
la sortie de la sage système du vote
alors le vote
donc chaque spectateurs et spectatrices
représente un vote et le jury est
composé de 4 personnes représente 25% du
total des votes
donc c'est moitié-moitié son mot à dire
voilà on l'a dit ce sont des dates qui
sont consacrés pour la c'est le 15 c'est
pour les jeunes les actifs émergents
mais il ya aussi des artistes reconnus
alors cette année en plus ils font
l'ouverture
d'habitude on attend un petit peu on
fait durer le plaisir là on y va
d'autres d'office le 14 mars vous
accueillez jeff mills et tony allen un
petit os déjà sur ce dernier qui lui a
60 ans de carrière raconte enfin il faut
préciser la soixante dix huit ans il est
toujours très actif way we en
effectivement nous ce festival électro
chic avec ces deux artistes absolument
incontournable de la scène électronique
techno electro électro depuis des années
enfin jack schmitt deux années 80 et
tony allen depuis années 60
ils ont en plus sorti un album ensemble
cette saison et
donc voilà donc ça avait sens pour nous
que de les accueillir on a vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir à les accueillir
chez nous vraiment c'est un événement on
disait justement que c'est l'électro il
ya plusieurs styles tony allen s'est en
allé combattre ici alors cessons figure
culte où ils l'afrobeat est ce que déjà
vous pouvez présenter un petit bonjour
ville alors justement tony allen c'est
voilà c'est le maître incontesté de
l'afrobeat qui montre bien à quel point
les musiques électroniques sont un
brassage de beaucoup de styles de
musique puisque l'afrobeat s'est
popularisé dans les années 70 en afrique
et mel mélange des musiques
traditionnelles nigériane du champ de
lave du funk du jazz
donc voila c est justement quand on a
quand on contacte ses figures de la
musique électro qu'on leur dit vous avez
joué dans le berceau presque de la
french touch comme enfin se passait ce
qu'ils veulent toucher ce qu'ils sont
soins depuis son aspire aussi je sais
pas à quel point je pense qu'ils
arrivent aussi avec leurs
voilà alors leur parcours qui est
absolument incroyable donc
donc voilà en tout cas ils ont ils ont
répondu présent c'est à dire en effet
revenir sap a été difficile pour nous
non non mais pourquoi eux en particulier
vous disais ça vous sembler normal de
les inviter ces pionniers là c'est le
propos de premier choix ces artistes ah
oui je pense que le choix moi je les ai
pas programmer personnellement donc ses
jo avec 15 du rejet directeur de l'undd
des ajustements bout jusqu'à la
comptable vous avez peaufiner où vous
êtes dit cela il les faut oui je pense
que voilà je pense que je vais aller
gainsbourg g a très vite arrêté son
choix sur ce duo d'artistes justement
parce que ils ont fait un album ensemble
parce qu'ils ont une actualité et parce
que voilà ils sont sondés m voilà on a
très envie d avoir et l'album est tout
récent en plus septembre dernier donc ça
va première scène peut-être en france
voire en europe je sais pas en tout cas
pas très loin c'est sûr une bonne raison
avant de quitter j'aimerais qu'on dise
un mot sur une bonne actualité de
l'établissement là on va repartir un
petit peu plus tôt dans l'année 2018
le 10 décembre dernier la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles donc
la drive ile-de-france a labellisé londe
scène conventionnée d'intérêt national
pour la dent mais qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour vous qu'est ce que ça va
vous apporter en plus déjà ça nous
apporte une subvention supplémentaire de
la drac justement pour déployer un
projet dans ce qui était déjà existants
allons d'un depuis depuis la nomination
de james gray à sa direction
en tout cas ça va nous aime nous amener
à
[Musique]
voilà enfin car d une classe pour la
danse tout à fait particulière dans la
programmation et notamment peut-être de
la résidence d'artistes voilà de
l'accompagnement à la création
la danse va prendre plus d'ampleur
encore dans le projet de l'aude merci
beaucoup
cyril leroux d'adapter notre invitation
on repart vers le festival électro chic
en précise c'est du 14 au cern au 16
mars
et pour ceux qui voudraient se produire
sur scène le tremplin vous attend la
date limite le 1er février on l'a dit et
l'adresse internet l'adresse mail est
indiqué sur l'écran nathalie ou de biner
patrice à - ont un point commun leur
choix picturaux ces doses yvelinoise
manie le noir et le blanc pour créer
elle expose actuellement en duo à
guyancourt un dialogue rendue possible
grâce à art talent le concours d'un
visuel de guyancourt un dialogue qui se
contemple guyancourt propose une double
exposition des techniques différentes
qui se répondent elles font parler leur
environnement patricia - photographie la
nature des seuils d'attraper la la
poésie de l'instant et surtout l'instant
qui bascule qu'est-ce qui avant qu'est
ce qu'il ya après
une poésie une permanence qui sait
quelque chose qui se transforme en
permanence je travaille essentiellement
en noir et blanc je trouve que la
couleur est un peu bavarde avec un calme
un silence qui fait écho à l'inspiration
de natalio de binh la plasticienne se
nourrit du territoire du sol de la
marche et crée aussi en noir et blanc
c'est mon côté minimaliste certainement
je pense qu'avec une seule couleur on
peut tout faire
d'ailleurs que le noir le pur et très
puissant si on le dit lui si on peut
obtenir des grilles extrêmement doux et
j'aime bien pouvoir jouer aussi avec ses
contrastes
toutes les valeurs que l'on peut trouver
donne énormément faire de relief des
profondeurs
une rencontre initiée par la ville cette
double exposition prend racine au
printemps 2010 8 avec le concours rare
talent de guyancourt une complémentarité
aux douceurs en noir et blanc riez et
yang
plein de choses comme ça qui font que
c'était une évidence qu'elle était elle
pouvait exposer ensemble et qu'elles
sont complémentaires
leur amour du noir et blanc n'est pas le
seul point commun des artistes nathalie
haut débit n'est patricia - sont passés
par l'école des beaux-arts de versailles
un parcours parallèle qui s'expose
jusqu'au 2 février
[Musique]
après la musique électronique place aux
classiques et l'association pour la
musique classique à 50 ans deviennent
continue de faire découvrir et diffuser
ce style sur le territoire son président
nous a rejoint plateau hervé farges
bonjour bonjour alors encore debout
rendez-vous à écouter voix lors de très
très bons rendez vous donc de nous
sommes la 18e saison des solides de
lavilledieu donc cette venue en fait
d'institutionnels on a du public
maintenant qui vient même de paris parce
que nous avons à l'auditorium de trappes
des conditions acoustiques
extraordinaire et puis une proximité
avec le public entre le public et les
solistes et puis ses solides fonds des
programmes spécialement pour pour trappe
ce qui fait que ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel
et puis aussi ce sont des sols des
solistes engagé dire qu'ils veulent
absolument faire découvrir la très
grande musique dans les quartiers comme
on dit voilà c'est sur l'aspect
pédagogique dont on parle un peu plus
tôt aussi un aspect pédagogique dont on
pourra parler un peu après mais il ya
déjà en fait la volonté de fournir le
top du top en fait dans des quartiers
comme les merisiers attrapé ça pour eux
c'est un engagement important qui s'y
tiennent alors le premier rendez vous de
l'année c'est le 19 janvier à
l'auditorium de trappes vous l'avait dit
et là on pourra écouter le quatuor les
dissonances et avant d'en parler je vous
propose qu'on les écoute voulons
[Musique]
alors dans cet extrait ils ont joué du
chou vert mais le 19 janvier alors david
grimal hans peter hofmann david gaillard
et xavier phillips sont des quatre
musiciens ils vont interpréter hayden
dutilleux et beethoven
tout à fait alors en fait on tient
beaucoup à voir à la fois de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler avec la plagne
guillemets bien sûr deux des tubes
donc il est évident que haydn et
beethoven bon avec les quatuors ce sont
des merveilles mais on veut aussi faire
découvrir et c'est vraiment un objectif
important pour nous donc on a dans ce
projet aussi un quatuor de dutilleux
donc de dieu et un mois comme c'est
moins connu qui est décédé en 2013
récemment il est très connu dans le
milieu de la musique classique mais pour
ceux qui se méfient de la musique
contemporaine
quand il a créé le quatuor ainsi la nuit
et bien il a été bissé et il a eu un
succès absolument extraordinaire je
pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur il faut
en fait des découvertes moi même au tout
début les quatuors j'avais j'avais un
peu de mal à me faire et maintenant
c'est que du bonheur et ses voitures
c'est une formation très intéressant si
elle est très intéressante elle est
passionnante et la musique de chambre
c'est passionnant parce que vous n'avez
pas de chef
chaque instrument est important et vous
avez une complicité extraordinaire entre
les musiciens et alors c'est enfin je
vais alain pluss à l'auditorium sait on
le sent encore mieux parce qu'on est
très précis et après on plus le plaisir
c'est qu'on se retrouve après le concert
autour d'un d'impôts avec les musiciens
et on parle avec les musiciens et je
vous assure que ça c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et des deux côtés des
musiciens tiennent aussi beaucoup et le
public apprécie énormément
justement un mot sur ce quatuor là les
dissonances qui se produit régulièrement
à trappes
voilà alors les dissonances bas pour
vous pour vous dire c'est un quatuor qui
a notamment de
deux solistes quand je dis soliste ce
sont en fait des gens qui maîtrise
tellement leurs instruments que ils font
surtout des des concertos par exemple on
en reparlera pour marianne piketty
mais par exemple xavier phillips c'est
un violoncelliste absolument
exceptionnel et il a joué le concerto
pour violoncelle de dvorak à new york
avec rostropovitch à la baguette donc
vous voyez un peu le niveau
il y à aussi david gaillard qui est donc
altiste à l'orchestré de paris et ce
sont en fait des musiciens absolument
exceptionnelle et là ils ont formé alors
cette formation de musique de chambre le
quatuor mais aussi ils ont un orchestre
et sont à géométrie variable et ils ont
aussi un orchestre les dissonances dans
lesquels il joue dans les pupitres et
bon ben ali la semaine d'avant
comment le week-end prochain ils vont
jouer la philharmonie de paris
c'est le dot accéléré vers le 16 mars et
on va parler du concert symphonique
famille quel est le programme cette
année
cette année le programme ces deux
concertos pour violon et orchestre de
beethoven et il est précédé on n'aura
pas trop le temps d'en parler
dungeon x un avant goût voilà c'est du
teasing
voilà donc c'est le concerto pour violon
et orchestre de beethoven monk est un
qui est une merveille des merveilles
dirigé par marianne piketty la
directrice la directrice artistique des
solides et avait lieu qui est professeur
au conservatoire cnsm de lyon etc est
une qui est maintenant très connu et
reconnu elle a participé notamment une
croisière avec alain duault
voilà et puis lors qu'est ce que nous
avons créé qui est l'ensemble orchestral
de la vie dieu qui en fait grâce à ses
grands ces grands musiciens choisis des
jeunes issus des grands conservatoires à
rick et on les aide en fête a démarré
leur carrière et c'est sous la direction
de pierre calmelet cette année 1 c'est à
dire que maintenant
pierre calme au lait est devenu en fait
notre directeur artistique sur tout ce
qui est projet de développement culturel
voilà maintenant que ça va être quelque
chose superbe et puis il y aura aussi
une autre partie avec la maîtrise de
trappes qui va chanter avec la maîtrise
de rambouillet des grands airs d'opéra
un très beau programme est
malheureusement le temps si vous aimez
oui c'est à dire parler de toutes les
qualités de la p1 muscu l'opéra nos
pères et marées des concerts
pédagogiques certaine logique où on en
est à trois mille six cents enfants et
l'année vous voilà dans les moyens
d'enchaîner pour vous laisser porter par
la musique classique le premier rendez
vous à ne pas manquer c'est le 19 avril
et le quatuor dissonances à 18 heures à
18 heures
alors vous l'aurez compris la deuxième
partie de saison culturelle regorge de
nombreux rendez-vous concert-bal et
représentations encore expositions
d'autres dates à noter
à vos agendas
[Musique]
il y aura de quoi se régaler pour cette
deuxième partie de saison
pour les gourmands culturel impossible
d'échapper à la troisième édition des
rencontres in cité du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ils vous invitent à table du 16 au 23
mars pour qu'on se met à table et qu'on
mange pas ainsi comme dans certaines
cultures
d'où viennent certaines habitudes
alimentaires qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
nos aliments voilà une approche
anthropologique sociologique culinaire
ludique gustatives aussi puisqu'on va
voir certains spectacles au cours
desquelles on pourra sentir ressentir
boire manger
le 1er février le théâtre espace coluche
de plaisir accueille celle à la
chanteuse de variétés revient sur scène
avec le groupe astag pour un concert
rock
vraiment
je vais les yeux les toits
ce même mois le 15 403 présentent leur
nouvel album un concert avec une
nouvelle formation scénique pour écouter
nos canaux kippen d'antigue au nom des
quelque 1
[Musique]
enfin m
l'humour a aussi sa place de christelle
chollet à montigny le bretonneux à
christophe alévêque à maurepas en
passant par françois xavier demaison au
prix ismail en cours vous pourrez rire à
gorge déployée
j'ai dépensé beaucoup d'argent en payant
très cher une avocate pour qu'elle dise
du mal de mon ex femme ma mère le
faisait très bien et gratuit pour les
plus jeunes la culture est aussi au
rendez vous le public pourra faire des
enfantillages en famille avec aldebert
en mai à la ferme du mas néocons de
chaleur des super pouvoirs
super pour ims de nouveaux invités nous
ont rejoints en plateau chantal david et
pierre aguillon
bonjour à toutes les deux alors vous
faites tous les deux partie de la troupe
de la cie thème la compagnie
d'interprétation théâtrale de maurepas
et le 12 janvier prochain vous serez sur
la scène de l'espace albert camus à
maurepas et je crois savoir que le
public va rire alors vous allez
présenter une pièce de pierre chesnot un
hôtel particulier
chantal david vous êtes le rôle
principal un petit mot sur cette pièce
eh bien je suis une veuve d'ambassadeurs
qui suite à ce breuvage se trouve dans
une situation pécuniaire plutôt délicate
aussi elle souhaite malgré tout gardé
son hôtel particulier qui est en bordure
du bois de boulogne et cherche une
solution quand un soir débarque chez
elle une vieille amie qu'elle n'a pas vu
depuis des années qui arrivent de rio et
qui lui demande si vous lui prêtez son
hôtel particulier pour recevoir son
amant quelques jours par semaine donc
elle accepte mais ce qu'elle ne sait pas
c'est que sa famille malte on va la
trahir en quelque sorte parce qu'elle va
aussi faire un complot un peu contraire
puisque elle va elle va faire des rendez
vous coquin avec des messieurs en mal
d'amour
donc moi je suis au courant de rien et
quand je le découvre je suis
complètement atterrée par ce que j'ai un
frère qui est commissaire divisionnaire
de police et vingt six heures ça à la
brigade des moeurs
donc je mets vraiment je suis
complètement désespéré je veux la mettre
à la porte et tout mais elle elle me
menace de tout révéler donc je suis
obligé de subir cette situation
et finalement ça donne des qui propos
des situations cocasses des portes qui
claquent des halles
et des sorties des rencontres des
changements de costumes bon saint géréon
je vous dise oui et puis à la fin tout
le monde y trouve son compte bien
réunion depuis le début de la semaine
nous est en résidence donc à l'espace
albert camus puisqu il participait à
pleins feux sur les planches qu'est ce
que le festival vous apporte
écoutez le festival nous apporte une
certaine notoriété en particulier d'être
parmi vous donc de faire connaître notre
troupe un peu mieux mon amour pas nous
nous nous sommes une tomme à bord fois
depuis 2001 enfin la compagnie a été
créée en 2001 et depuis cette date elle
l'a toujours toujours plus bénéficier
chaque année
de l'équipement albert camus c'est à
dire le sujet de l'équipement que de la
technique
donc là nos soutiens vous apporte un
soutien de lumière de l'uniat son
musique etc
donc on décore enfin là on est bien très
bien encadrés ça nous permettait très
bien travaillé et l'a donc la
particularité de revenant au festival
donc c'est que bon c'est tout
tout est concentré en même temps puisque
d'autres troupes vont jouer donc la
lumière et braqués sur nous et ça ça
nous permet de toucher un plus large
public
vous disiez vous existez depuis 2001
mais on le précise et des amateurs
passionnés peu de répétitions
une fois par semaine avoir eu dans les
dernières dans les ternésiens
enfin les jours j'imagine que ça
représente de longs mois de travail
ah oui on manque en trois semaines un
peu comme un accouchement
c'est variable côtoya il ya toutes les
contraintes liées à une troupe donc
donc il ya des gens oui il faut
harmoniser un petit peu la vie d'une
partie de la troupe qui est qui sont
retraités et d'autres qui sont actifs
donc bon là ça c'est une organisation
une cohésion à créer qu'on arrive à
faire une vivre depuis 2001 donc et avec
dans le plaisir
chantal d'aller chaque année vous
choisissez surtout des comédies où il
souhaitait faire rire oui oui oui c'est
le but essentiel comédie bien sûr de
boulevard et aussi comédies policières
sis à ceux ci on peut trouver parce que
comme on est nombreux il faut pouvoir
trouver des pièces avec le nombre de
femmes et d'hommes aux corrections
douzaine d'adhérents oui oui avec oui
oui 12 ans de metteur en scène sofie
goos leur cadeau qui nous suit au chat
qui nous anime depuis le début alors est
ce qu'on peut dire que la cites m m 4,2
boulevard ça faisait très fait de
l'histoire de pierre chesnot oui oui
voyez ça oui c'était un peu on a une
époque
or là aussi la troupe a joué du feydeau
nôtres et donc là en fonction on est on
étudie la pièce en fonction des ja de la
distribution de capacité et puis du côté
actif à deux ils vont des pièces qui
nous soutiennent c'est à dire que ce les
situations sont des quiproquos des
choses incongrues qui font que ça fait
rire et que ça nous aide nous dans notre
représentation
merci voilà je viens à travestir pour
vous découvrir sur scène en rendez vous
donc à l'espace albert camus de mort
passé le samedi 12 janvier les
réservations sont à faire sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de la page et on
passe maintenant à notre agenda
depuis ce mardi le conservatoire des
arts de montigny le bretonneux exposé
françois bellefontaine photographe a
capturé dans son objectif les gens de la
ville
ces clichés sont à découvrir jusqu'au 18
janvier ils sont douze à devoir juger un
garçon accusé de parricide il faut
l'unanimité pour prononcer un verdict
l'acquittement ou la chaise électrique
douze hommes en colère est présenté au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir le
samedi toujours d'hui extraits
messieurs je réclame votre intention qui
nous reconnaissons l'accusé coupable
environ la chaise électrique
la cegos du fonds vert comme ça sans
sourciller
quel monde on sait juger une avance
comme aujourd'hui c'est du temps perdu
au moins on est sûr que cette affaire
avait l'équivalent coupable lève la main
11 votes coupable vous le croyez nos
jours je n'en sais rien un voisin le
bretonneux près de 80 musiciens
reprennent des standards de rock et pop
rock mais propose aussi des compositions
originales
un concert à vivre à la salle de la tour
à l'occasion des scènes de multi son
bébé il débute à 15 heures ce dimanche
13 janvier toujours à voisins le
bretonneux un concert à quatre et simon
isabelle l'évêque françoise frey et leur
coignières sont en concert spectacle au
centre alfred de vigny le 12 janvier à
20h45 danser au congo c'est se battre
deux fois avec monstres delavallet
bidiefono mêle danse musique live chant
et performance le chorégraphe congolais
présence en avons très hâte de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines extraits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]